papa papa hey tu vas bien pourquoi oui bientôt
monsieur non je vais bien je vais bien c'est bon
tu en veux hmm d'accord penses-tu que
tu seras prêt pour l'ouverture demain
ouais ouais ouais eh bien je veux dire que les aperçus sont à
peu près naufrage nous  Je ne peux pas
sembler passer une performance sans maintenant faire
rage ou faire rage Je suis fauché
Je ne dors pas du tout comme vous le savez
et cette pièce essaie en quelque sorte de se sentir
comme une version déformée majeure de moi
-même qui continue juste  me suivant partout et
comme me frappant dans les couilles avec ça je suis
comme un tout petit marteau j'ai dit quelle
était la question